men are finding women over in the west
so this is I think it's alienates it's
feminism yeah I think the alienate smell
I think it gives um
I think it gives women a false kind of
um
sense of entitlement and I think that
it makes them feel like victims even
though they probably weren't even alive
when uh times
exactly so they don't even know what
already happened I think that um it
makes them feel like the victim so it
gives them the right to act a certain
way and treat men a certain way and it's
it's quite sad really because I think we
both lose it's because we're feminism
allowed women to be bailed out of every
single bad decision that we make ever
like if we want to if we want to sleep
around there's birth control yeah if
that doesn't work we have abortion if
that doesn't work you can get um
government assistance for being a single
mother
um if that doesn't work
um you can you know marry someone it
does could be the father or your kid
could not
um and then you know leave him and take
half yeah yeah
[Laughter]
I did not get a penny Okay
and then and then on top of that like um
foreign
I mean men you know commit like suicide
a lot of times after these divorced so a
lot of times like women make bad
decisions at the expense of man it also
allows us if we want to be homeless
there's women's shelters too there's
actually um for this hostels for men as
well
there's a friend of mine not really
there was a friend of mine who was in
Iran and he was talking to this lady
who's like an Auntie of his wife a woman
that he was about to marry and she said
how many houses do you have in in
England he said I'll just have the one
house it was really you only have one
house I have two houses he said yeah
that's because I didn't get divorced
twice
[Laughter]
what do you think um with the beautiful
majestic creatures
they say it's like Cheaper to Keep Her
Like why yes yes she's like why does
that a phrase yeah
it's true so feminism is one of the
reasons I think why the men are flocking
to outside of the West and then because
feminism is messed up it also confuses
um women about like what men actually
want I mean how many I've had girls on
the show that like genuinely think that
men care about your job they don't give
a [__] and they don't care about body
count yeah no they actually do care
about your body can and we don't care
about your job yeah
you know what I mean I mean I mean I
think
how many girls clothes that have called
Lizard 10.
so what are you gonna say go ahead no I
was gonna say that like obviously if
you're dating in your like your pool and
you've got an amazing job then surely
you you want a partner that like matches
you in some math work so your job not
necessarily I don't know I'm not a man
so maybe not maybe not all men but I
think I think the demographic men who
want their women to actually be
successful successful in some days
I don't care about a woman's job what
she does but I want it to not be not
involve her being naked or anything like
that and I want it to be something that
she enjoys
um and
that's about it really yeah like I I you
know that's it but there's still a level
and I wanted to have one it would be
nice if she has one yeah so it's like
women like we're attracted to the CEO of
a company like I've used this example
before but Donald Trump and Melania okay
I don't I'm not talking about politics
but who's better looking him or him or
Melania yeah right she's better looking
and it's not the same thing for Oprah
like there aren't men lining up to bang
Oprah but there's there's I'm sure
Donald Trump even look Donald Trump even
looking how he does has women lined up I
just like to say Oprah if you ever see
this I am willing to do this
I am willing and capable
statues out there like
you're gonna give her a ring too I'm I
am well I mean I may not be able to
afford the kind of ring she can never
but we can maybe put it on like payments
maybe at her credit card no I I think
like I said when it comes to feminism
like the reason why you know men are
opting out like women you've done many
Street interviews Perl when you've asked
women about like body cam does body
count matter and they're like no body
count doesn't matter because if a man
worries about body count then he's a
it's like yeah this is why I'm gonna run
titles like this is why men are going
outside because body count matters yeah
yeah it doesn't matter to women
sometimes I get it but to men 100 yeah
because I fully believe that I mean even
if a man tells you I don't care about it
just tell me as soon as you tell them
do not tell him ladies this is how I
know it matters because if there's a
woman that I think is amazing
with that body count comes certain
behaviors and habits and and also ethics
I think and and morals and that will
permeate through your relationship so
you may not know her but yeah
I think I've got a really good barometer
for that I can tell well you know so
yeah
I can pretty much tell I think most guys
can tell if someone's uh
had a lot of people
you'll be surprised it's a feeling it's
an attitude and a lot of the time those
women tend to be less feminine actually
funnily enough
because every it's like every body
there's more trauma exactly and so and
no just being real like unless you're
unless you're the type of girl that
doesn't attach right which I don't think
men typically want
um like there's more trauma with each
guy you're with yeah and so that's why
guys can smell a high body count
energetically you also take the shot
smells blood trust me every time you're
with somebody you're taking on their
energy I mean for me I do think
sometimes people have had many lives in
a sense of you you can get someone that
you know has had a high body count but
they've completely kind of turned that
around and they're not like that anymore
and I think
but I was like Dad do you think like
people change over time and he says yes
they get worse so whatever Behavior you
see that you don't like like it's gonna
be worse yes 30 years and I just think
like you can you can hide it and some
simp won't see it but if you have like
you're gonna have behaviors that are
going to show you show him exactly what
like what you are and I just don't think
like you can hide it forever yeah like
it's hard to be like you said five I
just heard about this x that X
yeah I said might allow it because they
don't think they can do better yeah yeah
that's what happens quite often if you
had like 30 dicks inside you right and
like you're gonna like a guy will
eventually see that you've had 30 dicks
inside you he will eventually because
the thing is your like you said your
behaviors will show it
that is that is why women who have had
most women who have had more than what
five bodies are more likely to get
divorced or your chance your chance of a
happy marriage and okay people don't
like this study so there's a couple
different ones but
um if you're a virgin on your wedding
night you have an 80 chance of a happy
marriage there's a couple studies that
say 60 to 70 percent so it depends which
one but it drops to a 25 chance after
like five to seven Partners so you're
basically ruined after like five to
seven because yeah because you're okay
because you're comparing your guy with a
consciously or subconsciously to those
guys and you're like was he like that
was he like that guy is he like that guy
for me for me an analogy of the body
counting for women is it's kind of like
um when you first get on the internet
and you check the comment sections and
you see all the people talking bad about
you and giving you more and more [__]
eventually you desensitize to it you
become you know you be you harden
effectively and you no longer get
affected as much by the comment section
as you used to when you first did and
that is the same with women who have
more and more Partners is eventually
you're you are not because you get hurt
you get heartbroken you this is a coping
mechanism within a human being they
don't want to be hurt anymore and your
body will figure out a way to protect
you from being hurt and that will mean
usually you will become more of a
distant person and you will never fully
commit yourself to the next relationship
because you know that the previous one
really hurts so now you also not the one
that felt really good the alpha Widow
that as well you know the one that felt
really good in your life
I actually have a question for the guys
yeah would you take a girl okay she's
got what would you say her questions
what would you guys say is a high body
count hi just give me give me a number
20. can we say 20 is high yeah okay
that's like medium high yeah um okay so
let's say
really high okay so let's say 25 yeah
okay her body counts 25.
um however she's never she's never okay
she's never gone back to an ex ever
or you can date a girl that's had five
but there's one X she's been sleeping
with on and off
for seven years that's a good question
on every relationship that ends that's
the guy she goes back to oh yeah she's
done she's awful we did no which would
you pick which would I pick yeah
I know and please don't say neither you
gotta pick one it's only fun this way
tell me the first one again so she's 20
she has her body counts 25 yeah
um like all things equal looks
everything else is equal one girl's body
counts 25 she's never gone back to an ax
the other girl's body count is five
I'm picking the X I'm picking the one
with 25. 25 yeah that's wild really yeah
so you would pick the X yeah because I
mean I'll tell you what yeah if she
keeps going back to the same guy she's
kept going back to the same guy after
the breakup yeah yeah if she keeps doing
that after the breakup so that means is
it only after the breakup or she's been
is a funny business going in between
um you don't know this is just bro you
know there has to be an emotion all
right if I if I actually believe that
she's only going off but back to that X
after the breakups yeah then I'll go
with the one with five in the boyfriend
100. but
I would have to really trust her yeah I
I don't know why
I feel like I feel like I feel like I
would recommend the one I don't think
I'd recommend it yeah yeah I'll get rid
of point for them to be fair but like I
feel like if that's you I feel like the
one that's more dangerous is the one
that keeps like the situation because
every girls who say there's a
situationship for six years yeah it'll
be on my mind that's why I said that but
I'm saying if we've built up that level
of trust if we've spoken about it and I
you know I I don't trust it I hardly
trust anybody to be honest wow so why
yeah
anyway so so no but like I would I'll
choose if we've got a certain level of
trust and also part of me would believe
that like you know I you know
I'd read Alpha widower
that would be my my Outlook anyway I
might not be right but I wouldn't be
threatened by the guys
what if he was Michael B Jordan the same
way
[Laughter]
right now yeah but like what
you have to see him more because he's
famous if he was just a normal guy
walking down
the reason why Michael G Jordan in my
personal point of view loses point is
because he chose Laurie Harvey yeah
right and Lori Harvey had been passed
around the industry
I'm not even gonna say a bad word
against him
but the thing is his choice in women is
skewed yeah he's got he doesn't know
he's doing as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible